[Musique]
dominique prépare le souper
lorsqu'on sonne à la porte un vendeur
itinérant lui fait miroiter les
économies qu'ils feraient avec des
panneaux solaires
au bout d'une heure de blabla dominique
est conquis ici sur le champ un contrat
de vingt mille dollars
mais la nuit porte conseil le lendemain
matin dominique revient sur sa décision
il ne veut plus de panneaux solaires
mais il entend des coups de marteau les
ouvriers sont déjà au travail peut-il
résilier ce contrat si le produit est
déjà installée oui nous avons vérifié
dans quatre provinces et une personne
sollicitée à son domicile par un
commerçant itinérant a droit à un délai
de dix jours pour annuler son contrat
sans frais ni justification
et si le vendeur a posé ses panneaux
avant c'est un risque qu'il prend si
dominique lui envoie une avis de
résiliation
le vendeur devra tout enlever à ses
frais et le rembourser au complet le fin
mot de l'histoire
si un vendeur itinérant vous court
circuiter vos droits ne tombez pas dans
le panneau